والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
فقراءتنا موصوله في مباحث من السيره من
كتاب زاد المعاد من هدي خير العباد
لشمس الدين
ابن قيم الجوزيه
الحافظ رحمه الله تعالى
وابن القيم
يطلق عليه ويصح اطلاق اسم الحافظ
او تسميه الحافظ
والحافظ في لغه المحدثين
من زاد في حفظه على مئه الف من احاديث
رسول الله واسانيدها
وكذلك هو فقيه
بل هو محقق من الفقهاء خاصه في المذهب
الحنبلي اذ هو حنبلي المذهب في الاصل وان
كان لا وان كان لا يتجمد على راي
من الاراء دون الدليل فاذا صح الدليل فهو
مذهبه رحمه الله
ومذهب الامام احمد
يقال انه اقرب من حيث الدليل
على سنه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من حيث
الدليل
وذلك ان الامام احمد
هو
كان اخر الاربعه المشهورين
وكثر في زمنه
الحديث
ودنت المصنفات والمسانيد في الحديث وكثر
مشايخه من الحفاظ
وانتقل الحديث الى العراق في زمنه الحديث
بدا في المدينه
وكان له
وقته وزمنه وعهد ثم انتقل الى العراق
ثم انتقل الى ما وراء النهر
يعني كان اقوى الناس في الحديث
والمكان الذي
يضرب اليه اكباد الابل من اجل اخذ الحديث
كان اولا الى المدينه ثم انتقل بعد ذلك
الى العراق حيث انتقلت الخلافه ثم بعد ذلك
الى ما وراء النهر وهذا في زمن البخاري
ومسلم
واصحاب السنن كلهم من وراء النهر يعني من
فارس وفوق
ولذلك كان مذهبه اوسع المذاهب
قل ما تجد رايا معتبرا له دليل او حظ من
النظر الا
وللامام احمد رحمه الله قول به في مذهبه
فمذهبه واسع واحيانا الاقوال في المذهب
الواحد تكثر حتى يكون سبعه اقوال في مذهب
الامام احمد في المساله الواحده ومذهب
واسع ودراسته
صعبه من ناحيه الدليل لان الاستدلال كثر
والاحاديث
صحه في زمنه رحمه الله تعالى
وابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
هو
من العلماء المحققين والمحقق من العلماء
هو من
ياخذ الاراء التي سار عليها
العلماء من قبله
ويحررها ويبحثها من جديد
ثم ياتي بتحقيق له على هذا القول
ولذلك
فان هذه البحوث قد تجعل بعض
ارباب المذاهب الذين يتجمدون على المذاهب
فانها قد
تقيم قيامتهم
يعني مثل ما صار في زمن شيخ الاسلام ابن
تيميه وابن القيم
كانت تحقيق في مساله الطلاق
مساله الطلاق كانت مساله كبيره
كيف يعني يعني العلماء
كان اكثرهم
يقول بي وقوع الطلاق بالثلاث
دفعه واحده دون ان يتخلل
كل طلاقين منها رجعه وهذه مساله مهمه
يعني واحد زعلان غضبان
قام على مرته قال انت طالق طالق طالق هكذا
يحصل هذا كثيرا في زمن النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم الرسول اعتبر هذه واحده
حتى لو قالها الف مره هذه واحده لانه
الطلاق المعتبر لا بد يقع طلاق وبعدين
رجعه رجعها الى عصمته
ويعلمها بذلك والله عز وجل امر
باستشهاد الشهود على هذه الراجعه ثم بعد
ذلك انشاء ان يطلق فهذه مساله
كانت في عهد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقعت واعتبرها واحده
وان تكرر اللافظ
ثم بعد ذلك كثر هذا بين المسلمين
والله عز وجل غلط في هذه المساله
وقال سبحانه وتعالى واذا طلقتم النساء
فبلغنا اجلهن
فامسكوهن بمعروفنا وسرحوهن بمعروف
وقال فامساكم بمعروف او تسريح باحسان
والله عز وجل
قال
ختاما في هذه الايه ولا تتخذوا ايات الله
هزوا
كان الناس
كانوا في الجاهليه عندهم فكره الطلاق
وعندهم فكره
العده لكن العده العده كانت فيه الجاهليه
سنه
كانت حولا طلق مرته العده سنه فماذا يصنع
احدهم في الجاهليه يطلق امراته
ثم يجعلها تمكث في عدتها الى نهايه العده
ثم اذا كادت واشرفت على نهايه العده
قال ارجعتك
وبعد ما يرجعها برضو طلقتك وبعدين يعيد
العده هكذا تعذيبا
للمراه
فالله عز وجل جعل العده ثلاثه قروب
يعني ثلاث حيضات
وجعل هذا من المحرم وقال ولا تتخذوا ايات
الله هزوا وقال ولا تمسكوهن ضرارا لتعتدوا
والانسان الغضبان فانه قد يقول اشياء في
حال الرضا او في حال
الهدوء لا يريدها ولا يعتقدها
وانما يدفعه الى الاستعجال الغضب
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اعتبرها طلقه
واحده
ثم كثر والناس لم يرتدعوا عن ذلك ففي عهد
عمر
قال عمر رضي الله عنه
انا نجد الناس استعجلوا فيها
فلنجعلها كما قالوا
من اجل الا يتجاسر احد على هذه الفعله
غلط فيها وجعل في القضاء
ان الطلاق هذا واقع هذا كان سياسه في زمن
عمر رضي الله عنه والسياسه ما رميها واسعه
والسايس الذي يكون القاضي او الامير او
الخليفه او ما شابه ذلك فله ان يرى بعض
هذه الاراء وان يضبط الناس
فعمر رضي الله عنه الزمهم بها
لاحظوا الكلمه الزمهم بما يقولون ردعا لهم
عن هذا الفعل
لكن في كتاب الله
في سنه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هي واحده
لكن القاضي اذا راى مصلحه فانه يجوز له
فسخ العقد بين الزوجين حتى لو ما رضي حتى
لو ما رضت كمان
فعمر رضي الله عنه من هذا المنطلق
فكثير من العلماء
واصحاب المذاهب الاربعه ساروا
ساروا على
ناهج عمر رضي الله عنه في هذا
لكن شيخ الاسلام وابن القيم
وعلماء هذه الفتره حققوا
الفرق بين القضاء وبين
وبين الحكم في كتاب الله كما هو
اصلا
القاضي قد يقضي بقضاء وهذا القضاء لا
يخالف كتاب الله
لكن يغلظ على بعض الناس من اجل ماذا من
اجل حفظ الناس لكن اذا كثر الجاهل بين
الناس والناس استعجلوا واصبح الكلام كثيرا
واللغط كثير فان
الاصل الساعه في هذه المساله فشيخ الاسلام
حقق ان هذا الطلاق في قضاء عمر يعني في
الزام عمر
للمقتضي اليه
ان هذه
محسوبه كما قال لكن الاصل في السنه
ان هذه الطلقات لا بد ان يتخللها بين كل
طلاقين منها رجعه
طلاق الصحيح تكون المراه
طاهر من
الحيض
وتكون المراه في طهر لم
يمسها بها زوجها يعني ما وقع جماع
بينهما في هذا الطهر من اخر حيضه ما وقع
بينهما جماع ثم الرجل وهو متسيطر على
اعصابه
لا نقول
ان طلاق الغضبان لا يقع لا طلاق الغضبان
يقع
لكن في فرق في درجات الغضب اذا كان الغضب
الى حد الجنون او الى حد ان الانسان يتكلم
الكلام وهو غير متسيطر على على
اعصابه وعلى كلامه وغير ضابط لكلامه فان
هذا غير محسوب
ثم له ان يطلق في هذه الحال فقط
فاذا طلق
فانه من اجل ان يطلق مره اخرى ويكون هذا
الطلاق واقعا فانه لا بد انه يسترجعها
جعلها راجع الى عصمته والله عز وجل امر
بالاشهاد على ذلك يجيب شهود اثنين كمان
تقول اشهدكم انني ارجعت فلانه الى عصماتي
او نحو من ذلك
ثم بعد ذلك يسوق طلاق ثاني وهكذا هذا هو
الطلاق في اصل حكم الاسلام وهذا هو راي
شيخ الاسلام ابن تيميه رحمه الله
واوذي من اجل هذا الراي كثيرا
كان كثير من العلماء في زمنه
انتقدوا هذا الراي منه مع انه قتل هذه
المساله بحثا
واستدلالا وتدليلا وتقعيدا
الا انهم
تجمدوا على راي المذهب وعلى قول المذهب
فسجن رحمه الله سجن من اجل هذه هذه الفتوى
هذه التحريرات
ابن القيم رحمه الله
تبعه في هذا الراي وكتب فيه
واطنب في الكتاب عن هذه المساله في مثل
كتابي اغاثه اللهفان وغيري من الكتب وابن
كثير كذلك
فسجنوا
هؤلاء ايضا واذوا كثيرا
ولكن الله عز وجل يقول
[Silence]
وغيرهم
وبقيت هذه الكتب والمقالات محفوظه وهذه
الفتاوى محفوظه
وذهب غيظ اعدائهم
وماتت اتهاماتهم معهم ولله الحمد والمنه
على كل حال
المقصود من هذا الكلام
ان ابن القيم رحمه الله
هو اكبر تلميذ لابن تيميه لشيخ الاسلام
وكثير من الناس يطعن في شيخ الاسلام ابن
تيميه لكنه يثني على ابن القيم وهما صيام
زي بعض
صحيح خالف ابن القيم بعض مسائل
اختلف مع شيخه فيها الا انهم على نهج واحد
وعلى عقيده واحده وعلى منهج واحد
ولكن الفرق بينهما
الفرق بين
شيخ الاسلام ابن تيميه وشيخ الاسلام ابن
القيم لماذا وقع القبول
واصبح شاملا
ويصير مبغضي
شيخ الاسلام ابن تيميه يحبون ويثنون على
ابن القيم السبب طريقه القول
ابن تيميه رحمه الله كان فيه نوع من
الغلظه نوع من الشده في البحث
وقد وصف رحمه الله تعالى بانه قد يكرم
ويهين
في جلسه واحده ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني
يكون قائم على الضيف وفيه كل الاخلاق
الطيبه الا انه اذا صار البحث فانه قد
يهين الخصم وهو لا يقصد ذلك وانما من شده
كلامه كان موصوف بانه ليس حرب في
البحث وفي المجادله
فابن القيم رحمه الله
كانت سياسته
الطف بكثير
في اقواله وبحوثه وهكذا وان كان لابن
القيم ايضا
تغليظات والغل ظلام محلها لهم مكانها
في بعض المقامات لا يصلح فيها اللين لا
يصلح فيها الا الشده
لكن ابن القيم رحمه الله
كانت الفاظه يعني زي ما تقول مكسوه اكثر
فالمقصود من هذا الكلام ان ابن القيم رحمه
الله وابن كثير
والذهبي
ومن بعدهم ابن رجب رحمه الله
وابن ابي العز الحنفي كثير من هذه الاسماء
وهؤلاء العلماء الاكابر فانهم من شجره
واحده
من شجره واحده
واقول هذا الكلام لان
المغالطات تكفر بين الناس
المقال المغالطات كثرت بين الناس
واحيانا عامه الناس
يتلقون
بالسنتهم اقوالا
هي غير صحيحه
وغير دقيقه وغير مبحوثه وقد تكون اكذبات
من اعداء العلماء والعلماء مثل الانبياء
لازم يكون لهم اعداء لازم لازم
الله عز وجل جعل لكل نبي ماذا عدوا لازم
لكن بعض الانبياء مالهم اصحاب ولا واحد
امن فيهم
جاء في حديث ابن عباس ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
في البخاري ومسلم راى الامم اراه الله
سبحانه وتعالى الامم وارى
واراه كل
نبي ومعه امته والامه هنا يعني امه
الاستجابه الذين استجابوا لنبيهم
فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم فرايت النبي ومعه
ومعه
الرجلين والثلاثه
واريد النبي ومعه رجل واحد بس امن به وبعض
الانبياء
لم يكن معهم احد
وهذه من حكمه الله سبحانه وتعالى
لكن
وكذلك جعلنا لكل نبي عدوا من الشياطين
لان العدو
لا بد منه لا بد من العدو
للحق من اجل ان يظهر الحق تماما
لكن
الصاحب زياده خير لكن مش لازم
فعلى كل حال
العلماء لهم اعداء لازم يكون لهم اعداء
ويتسلط عليهم بعض السفهاء وبعض الكذابين
والوضعين
وقد يتسلط عليهم بعض العلماء
من جراء ذلك اقوال بين الناس
يتلقونها بالسنتهم وليست
من الحق وليست من ما ينبغي ان يقال في اهل
العلم
فشيخ الاسلام ابن تيميه رحمه الله
من افضل العلماء الاسلام في تاريخ الاسلام
قاطبه
وهؤلاء العلماء يعني اذا انا مثلا قلت لكم
تفسير
سمولي تفسير
اي تفسير اول تفسير يجي في ذهنك لما بقول
كلمه تفسير شو بيجي في بالكم
اه ابن كثير صح ولا لا
كتب الله عز وجل للقبول لتفسير ابن كثير
وابن كثير رحمه الله
من تلامذه ابن تيميه رحمه الله وينقل
اقواله كثيرا كثيرا ولكن ينقل هذه الاقوال
في تفسيره
ويؤيدها
ويدعمها لكن ما يذكر اسم شيخ الاسلام وهي
اقواله يعني في مقدمه
تفسير ابن كثير
كتب صفحات
نقلها تماما من
كلام شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله لكن ما نسب
هذا الكلام اليه بالحرف
لماذا لم ينسب هذا الكلام اليه
من اجل
السياسه بعض الناس
لا يستطيع ان ينظر الى
ماده الكلام وانما تضر تغره
المظاهر فاذا سمع ابن تيميه لا يرفضه
مهما كان في من يرفضه
واذا قيل ابن كثير
غيرنا الغلاف يقبلوا يقول ابن كثير قالوا
لا يدري انه اصلا ينقل عن شيخ الاسلام
وكذلك ابن القيم فعل رحمه الله في كثير من
كتاباته تجب ينقل بالحرف
عن شيخ الاسلام
وهذه من الحكمه
يقع هذا احيانا ان بعض العلماء يغني في
نسبه الكلام من اجل ان يقبله الناس
فعلى كل حال انا اذكر هذا الكلام
لانني
اسمع العامه كثيرا يتحرجون من شيخ الاسلام
ابن تيميه رحمه الله ولا يدرون لماذا
الا ان اهل البدع واهله
الاكذبات
والقصص المختلقه والاقوال
والاقوال المغلوطه
وينسبون الى شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله تعالى
وحصل نفس الشيء مع الامام احمد ابن حنبل
رحمه الله نفس الشيء تماما
المعتزله والجاهميه اذوه اذيه بالغه
على مسائل في اصول اعتقاد الاسلام
فبعض هذه الاقوال لسه
زي ما بيقولوا كتاكيت يعني ولاد وفرخات
هذول الجماعات لسه بنقول هذا الكلام عن
الامام احمد رحمه الله وكذلك عن ابي حنيفه
النعمان وكذلك عن
الامام مالك رحمه الله والشافعي والامام
احمد
فعلى كل حال لا يستطيع الانسان ان
يقبل ابن القيم ويرفض شيخ الاسلام لانه
كتابات ابن القيم تعتبر
شروح
على كتب شيخ الاسلام واقوال شيخ الاسلام
ابن تيميه رحمه الله ويشرح لذلك علماؤنا
كانوا
ينصحوننا بقراءه كتب ابن القيم رحمه الله
قبل
قراءه ابن كتب ابن تيميه لانها اسمك واصعب
واقواله
صعبه
وليست قريبه الى الفهم
لعلو كعبه رحمه الله تعالى في العلم على
كل حال
نحن لا نتحرج ان نقول شيخ الاسلام ابن
تيميه شيخ الاسلام كذلك ابن القيم يقال له
شيخ الاسلام ابن القيم رحمه الله
ولله الحمد والمنه
الدين
هذا
له اجداد وله
اسانيد تعود الى في رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم لله الحمد
واي شيء يختلق او يدسه الداسون او
الكذابون والوضعون فان العلماء يفندونها
تفنيدا لله الحمد يبينونها للناس
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله وجاء رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم الى ابي بكر نصف
النهار قد ذكرنا هذا في بدايه حجره الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وابو بكر
قال له فخذ بابي وامي احدى راحلتي هاتين
فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بالثمن
فاخذ بالثمن وهذا من المروءه
وامر عليا ان يبيت في مضجعه تلك الليل
واجتمع اولئك النفر يتطلعون
من صير الباب يريدون بياته يعني قتله ليلا
وغيله وياتمرون ايهم يكونوا اشقاها فخرج
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فاخذ
حفنه من البطحاء يعني من التراب
فجعل يذره على رؤوسهم وهو يتلو وجعلنا من
بين ايديهم سدا ومن خلفهم سدا فاغشيناهم
فهم لا يبصرون ومضى الى بيت ابي بكر رضي
الله عنه فخرج من خوخه فيه ليلى
وجاء رجل فراى القوم ببابه يعني بباب
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال ما تنتظرون
قالوا محمدا قال خبتم وخسرتم قد والله مر
بكم وذر على رؤوسكم التراب
فقاموا ينفضون عن رؤوسهم فلما اصبحوا قام
علي عن الفراش فسالوه عن النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم فقال لا علم لي به طبعا هو
استخلف عليا رضي الله عنه على امانات
الناس الناس كانوا يخلوا عند الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
اموالا
وقد تكون كنوزا
فهذا لي امانتي صلى الله عليه وسلم فهو
استخلف عليا على امانات الناس
عشان يعطي كل واحد امانته
ومكث علي رضي الله عنه كما يذكر ابن هشام
ثلاثا بعد خروج النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ثم
لاحقه في
الهجره ثم مضى وابو بكر وعلي رضي الله عنه
كان صغيرا في هذا الوقت يعني بجوز كان في
ال14 او نحو ذلك او بجوز اكبر يعني دون
العشرين ثم مضى وابو بكر الى غار ثور
فدخله وضرب العنكبوت على بابه وكان قد
استاجرا ابن اوريقط الليث كان قافيه وذلك
انه كان يحسن
الطرق
وكان ابن اريقت الليثي
مشركا الا انه كان امينا في
مهنتي وكان ماهرا بالطريق وهو على دين
قومه
وامناه على ذلك وسلم اليه راحلتيهما
وواعداه الغار بعد ثلاث يعني ثلاث ايام
وجدت قريش في طلبهما واخذوا معهم القافه
القافه جمع قافي
وهو من يتبع الاثر اثر الناس يعرف يلحق
وراء الاثار وماهر في الطرق وفي اتباع
اثار الناس حتى انتهوا الى باب الغار
وكان عامر ابن فهيم يرى عليهما غنما لابي
بكر ومكث فيه ثلاثا حتى خمدت عنهما نار
الطلب
وقد جاء في صحيح البخاري
ان
ابا بكر رضي الله عنه قال
يا رسول الله لو ان احدهم نظر الى قدميه
لا رانا
فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا تخف
وفي روايه اسكت يعني ما عليك من هذا
الحكيم ما بالك باثنين الله ثالثهما
وهذا ما ذكره الله سبحانه وتعالى في سوره
التوبه الا تنصروه فقد نصره الله باخرجه
الذين كفروا ثاني اثنين اذ هما في الغار
اذ يقول احدهما لصاحبي لا تحزن ان الله
معنا
ثم جاءهما ابن اريقط بالراحلتين فارتحل
واردف ابو بكر عامر بن فهيره يعني وراءه
وكان
يخدم ابا بكر رضي الله عنه وراعيا له
وسار الدليل امامهما وعين الله تصحبهما
واسعاده ينزلهما ويرحلهما
ولما ايس المشركون منهما جعلوا لمن جاء
بهما ديه كل واحد منها الدقيقه الدقيقه
كانت 100 ناقه
يعني باختصار يكون الواحد فقير
وياخذ 100 ناقه يصبح من اغنى اغنياء قومه
فهذه الديه كانت كبيره من قريش والله عز
وجل ذكر ان اهل الكفر ينفقون اموالهم
ليصدوا عن سبيل الله
فسيينفقونها ثم تكون عليهم حسره ثم يغلبون
والذين كفروا الى جهنم يحشرون
فلكل واحد منهما ديه
يعني 100 ناقه
عن
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم رسول الله 100
ناقه عن ابي بكر وهذا يدل على الحنك
والغيظ الذي ملا صدورهم ولله الحمد اماتهم
الله سبحانه وتعالى غيظا فان الله تعالى
انما يشفي صدور المؤمنين فجد الناس في
الطلب والله غالب على امره
فلما مروا بحي بني مدلج
بصر بهم رجل من الحي
فقال لهم لقد رايت بالساحل اسوده ما اراها
الا محمدا واصحابه ومن اربعه الحين
عندنا عامر ابن فهيره عندنا ابن اوريقط
الدليل وعنا ابو بكر والنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
مر
بقرب حي بني مدلج
وعارفين بالديه انتشر هذا الخبر والكل
بدور بده
بده يكسب هذه الديه
وهذه الديه عظيمه يعني كثيره ممكن
يقتسمها
تقسمها القبيله
فرجل من بني مدلج راى اسوده يعني
راى
اشياء سوداء في البعد
في الصحراء وقال ما اراهم الا
محمدا واصحابه
فكان مين جالس
كان جالس سراقه ابن مالك المدلجي
سمع هذا القول وطمع لكن لو هو خرج
يخرج معه قومه
فالديمه بتكون له لحاله دي الان لابد انه
يقتسمها مع مع قومه
ما بده يقتسم هذه الديه
فغم في المساله ماذا قال
ففطنا
سراقه فاراد ان يكون له الظفر خاصه وقد
سبق له من الظفر ما لم يكن في حسابه سبحان
الله سبق له من الظفر ما لم يكن في حسابه
هو اراد ان يختص بالديه الا ان الله
سبحانه وتعالى منعه اياها ومن رحمته كتب
له رحمه عظيمه
وذلك رحمه الاسلام فانه اسلم في فتح مكه
كما جاء في صحيح البخاري فقال بل هما فلان
وفلان
مش النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مش محمد وابو
بكر هذولا جماعه انا عارف انهم خرجوا مش
هم
خرج في طلب حاجه لهما ثم مكث قليلا سوى
حاله غير مهتم غير مكترث بالقصه ثم قام
فدخل خبائه وقال لخادمه اخرجي بالفرس من
وراء الخباء وموعدك وراء الاكمه الاكمه
يعنيه زي التله مكان المرتفع ثم اخذ رمحه
وخفض عاليه يخط به الارض حتى
ركب فرسه يعني هو متخبي وراء الاكمه ومعاه
الرمح الرمح طويل بدش جماعه ويشوفوا راس
الرمح من ورا
من ورا الاكمه يعني وين رايح سراقب بالرمح
فجعل يجر رمحه ويخفض عالي الرمح من وراء
الاكمه
فلما قرب منهم
وسمع قراءه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وهو
لا يلتفت وابو بكر يكثر الالتفات خوفا على
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال ابو بكر يا رسول الله هذا سراقه قد
رهقنا يعني ادركنا
فدعا عليه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فساخت يدا فرسه في الارض طبعا انكب عن
ظهره
وجاء في سيره ابن هشام
ان سراقه لما حصل معه هذا الموقف
ايدينا الفرس ساخذ في الارض
وانكب من على الفرس
وكانت معه
الازلام
الازلام زي صلاه الاستخاره
للمشركين انا ذاك
هي تكون عاده ثلاثه اسهم رؤوس الاسهم
مكتوب على واحد يفعل وعلى الثاني لا تفعل
والثالث
ما عليه اشي كان اذا اراد احدهم او هم
احدهم بفعل شيء فانه يقتسم بالازلام
وجعلوا هذا من دين ابراهيم هيك قالوا
وعلقوا صوره
يزعمون ان هذه الصوره
ابراهيم عليه السلام واسماعيل
وفي ايديهما الازلام والعياذ بالله وهذا
نوع من الشرك والله عز وجل يقول يا ايها
الذين امنوا انما الخمر والميسر والانصاب
والازلام رجس من عمل الشيطان فاجتنبوه
لعلكم تفلحون
وابدلنا الله سبحانه وتعالى بهذا ماذا
يعني ابدلنا بالازلام ايش في الاسلام
شو بسوي الواحد لما بده يعمل شيء
ومتردد صلاه الاستخاره
لذلك تجد في
حديث جابر في الصحيح قال كان رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم يعلمنا الاستخاره كما
يعلمنا الايه من القران
ليش لتاكيد هذا الامر ناس كانوا يقتسمون
بالازلام ويتطيرون
فجعل الله سبحانه وتعالى ذلك رجسا من
الشيطان وابدل الناس ماذا كلمات من عنده
اللهم اني استخيرك بعلمك واستقدرك بقدرتك
واسالك من فضلك العظيم فانك تعلم ولا اعلم
وتقدر ولا اقدر وانت علام الغيوب وانت على
كل شيء قدير يعني الفاظ موجوده لكن
المقصود لنا صلاه الاستخاره ولهم الازلام
هذه نعمه عظيمه من الله فهو خرج هذه
الازلام
وسحب فاذا سحب الذي لا يريد يعني لا تفعل
جعله الله سبحانه وتعالى هكذا
ما اقتنعش راكب الفرس وهجم مره اخرى
فساخت
يدا الفرس
واكبه الفرس عن ظهره واقتسم ايضا مره
ثانيه بالازلام وخرج الذي لا يريد اي لا
تفعل لا تقدم على هذا الامر
فهنالك سلم سراقه
وعلم انه لن يسلط عليهم
وهذا من
من دلائل النبوه من ايات رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
بالنسبه الى الازلام
في اشياء استعملها المسلمون هي في اصلها
نوع من
هذا
وبعض العلماء يلحق بالازلام
ذكرها الله سبحانه وتعالى انما الخمر
والميسر والانصاب والازلام ورجس من عمل
الشيطان فاجتنبوه لعلكم تفلحون
فالاصل ليست الصوره وانما
وانما
الامر والتفكير والتركيب يعني الواحد لو
ما كان عنده اسهم وانما جعل ورقات مثلا او
جعل
حجارا او شيء مثل هذا
حجاره يكتب عليها واحد يصمره وواحده وبيضه
واحده هذا ايضا
اقتسام الاقتسام بالازلام وهو نوع من
الشرك
والعلماء يذكرون كذلك ما يسمى عند العامه
بالاستفتاح
ليش هو الاستفتاح
يعني الواحد جاي في باله اشي
فباخذ المصحف
وبفتح وبحطه صبعه
وهذه الايه اللي بقراها للمساله تبعته
هذا الحاقه والعلماء بالازلام
وانما لنا صلاه الاستخاره بس
واما الاستفتاح هذا فلا يجوز
على كل حال
قال
سراقه لان سراق اسلم يوم الفاتح فقال قد
علمت ان الذي اصابني بدعائكما فادعوا لي
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم دعاه الى
الاسلام
فابى ان يدخل في الاسلام الا انه
وعد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الا يكون
مع من يقاتلون ولا هو يقاتله
مهما كان مش مقتنع بالاسلام ولكن
شر مكفوف وكان
كان عظيما مبجلا فيه قومه
كانت وراه قبيله سراقه رضي الله عنه
فعاهد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الا يقاتله والا يكون مع من يقاتلون
فتركه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم على
على ذلك
واراد
من النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان يكتب يكتب له كتابا فهو علم في هذه
اللحظه اللي صار مع فارس واللي صار في مع
ازلامه واللي صار مع عرف انه المساله اعظم
من مجرد رجل يدعي النبوه
وقال سراقه كما في صحيح البخاري قال فعلمت
يعني في ذلك الوقت لما صارت هذه
المساله لما صارت
هذه القصه علمت انه
سينصره الله عالم انه سيكون
سيدا وظاهرا على العرب
فطلب منه ان يكتب له كتابا حتى اذا
فتحت مكه
واصبحت العظيم
في العرب انه يكون لي الامان
فكتب له رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ذلك
فعلا لكن كان له اكثر من هذا
سنذكره في
هذا نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى الله
عليه وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين وجزاكم الله خيرا الله
اكبر الله اكبر